a stroke occurs when the blood flow in
part of your brain is blocked
after just a few minutes the starved
brain cells begin to die
normally the brain receives blood via
two major pairs of arteries
which branched throughout brain tissue
and supply your brain cells with a
constant flow of oxygen glucose and
nutrients necessary for their functions
in one type of stroke ischemic stroke
an artery in your brain Narrows
becomes completely blocked preventing
normal blood flow
blockage may be caused by a blood clot
also called a thrombus which forms in an
unhealthy artery of the brain
the lack of blood flow causes the tissue
the artery supplies to become starved or
ischemic
similarly the blockage may be due to an
embolus
a blood clot that forms elsewhere in the
body
travels to the brain
the embolus lodges in a narrowed artery
and obstructs blood flow
you
in contrast during a hemorrhagic stroke
abnormal bleeding disrupts normal blood
flow
for example in an intracerebral
hemorrhage Extro k--
vessel bursts spilling blood directly
onto your brain while robbing the
intended tissue of nourishment
both the hemorrhage and ischemia destroy
brain tissue
a subarachnoid hemorrhage Extro k--
occurs when a weak spot in a blood
vessel wall called an aneurysm bursts
and leaks blood into the tight space
between your brain and your skull the
high pressure bleeding results in
serious damage to brain tissue
immediate treatment for your stroke may
help to minimize brain cell injury and
death
if you have an ischemic stroke
you may be given medication to break up
the clot causing your stroke
later your doctor may recommend surgery
such as carotid endarterectomy to reduce
your risk of having another ischemic
stroke
in the case of hemorrhagic stroke
emergency surgery may be necessary
to repair damaged arteries
or reduce the pressure of the blood on
your brain
you may be given medication to help the
brains blood flow return to normal